- There may be a 99 arm accuracy on the line here.
- Wow.
- No pressure.
- This is what I've been waiting for.
- [Together:] Oh!
- What is up, and welcome to "Underrated,"
the No. 1 show to improve athletes'
video game ratings. Behind me in the box,
Nolan Arenado. Yes, eight-time Gold Glover
and just, he just smashes the ball.
But we need to know how he is in The Show.
That's why we got our pro gamer,
Ashley Sanders, to break it down.
- Nolan Arenado, one of the best
third basemen in recent MLB history.
When it comes to his bat,
he can do it all, whether it's contact,
power, drivin' in some runs,
Nolan is your guy.
So, of course, when it comes to attributes
like bunting, Nolan
Arenado is definitely underrated.
- Do you know what your
bunt rating is in The Show?
- I don't.
- Thirty-five.
What's the highest on the bunting rating?
- Probably 99.
- Wow. That is low.
- I need your ratings in The Show
for this next generation—
- Yeah.
- To be blown away.
- And I have a guy that's gonna help us get it there.
- All right, let's do it.
- We're gonna bring in Ramone.
I'm not even gonna look at him.
He's just comin' in. He's my heater in the back.
- Hey, what's happenin'? What's goin' on, man?
- You heard him talking about the ratings.
- Mmhmm.
- I wanna start off with an easy
one, his bunt rating.
- Right.
- How can we take this to the next level?
And why is he at a 35?
- Well, cuz he doesn't bunt. He doesn't
bunt. But you've got,
you got 100 on power versus
lefties, 99 fielding,
99 arm.
Not a lotta players in the game have 99s.
- Yeah.
- But, you know, everything matters.
You never know when you might
have to lay down that bunt.
So there's nothing
better than trying to do it.
- So what we've laid out
here, three targets.
If you get it in that initial white
or that back blue, that's one point.
The sweet spot's
that middle red for two points.
Anything else is minus-one.
And Ramone, correct meif I'm wrong.
With 10 attempts, he could go up 20 points.
- He could.
And that might take
you up past a 90 overall.
So who knew that your bunt rating
could be the thing that takes you past 90 overall?
- I would have never thought this—
- How does that make you feel?
- It makes me feel really good.
- It makes me feel—
- I really wanna lay these down.
- Yes.
- I got this.
- It's bunt time. Let's go!
- All right, Nolan,
let's lay down some bunts.
Start off on the first base line
whenever you're ready.
That's a beauty.
- [Arenado:] OK.
- [Lefkoe:] Sit!
- [Arenado:] Get in there.
- Hold on. Hold on.
- Is it in there? One point?
- It's the first one.
I think it's a one.
I wanna give you the two, but I think it's a one.
- That's a one.
- [Arenado:] I don't want handouts.
- [Lefkoe:] I gotta be honest.
Good speed.
- [Arenado:] No way. Same exact spot.
- [Russell:] Same spot.
- [Lefkoe:] OK.
- [Arenado:] Stay fair.
- White dirt.
Stay!
- Stay fair.
- [Russell:] Oooh. Oooh. Oooh.
- [Lefkoe:] Sit! Bang!
- That's on the line.
- [Lefkoe:] That right there is picture perfect.
That's in there.That's in there.
- [Russell:] That's in there.
- [Lefkoe:] That's two.
- That's gotta go.
- [Russell:] Slow grass.
- [Lefkoe:] So two, four, five, six, seven.
You're plus-seven.
That means if you hit all of these
into the twos, we can get up to plus-17.
It's on you. Hold it down, Nolan!
- Let's do it.
- [Lefkoe:] All right, third base line.
- Stay fair.
No! Oh, my.
- That's a foul. That's minus-one.
OK, deep breaths. Minus-two.
It's OK.
- The grass is a little high.
- Get through.
Oh, man.
- That's on the line.
- That's on
the line, and it counts!
Yeah, there it is.
- OK, there it is.
- [Lefkoe:] That's the money shot!
And now the final throw.
- There we go.
- And now he's got the grass.
Can we do the five now?
Cuz he's got it down. Bang!
Beautiful.
- I'll take it.
- All right, we went plus-seven
on the right.
We went plus-three on the left.
That's a plus-10.
- Yep, plus-10.
- Moving him from a 35 to a 45.
And you're happy to give those points?
- Happy. Happy to give those points.
- Cuz you watched it happen.
- We watched it happen.
And the grass wasn't on his side.
- Plus-10, how does that feel?
- It feels pretty good.
I had some close calls.
My BP thrower threw great right
there, and I let him down a little bit.
But—
- Wow.
- I gotta be better.
- [Together:] Team player!
- Unbelievable.
- Eight-time Gold Glove winner.
And when you look at his stats,
they match that. His fielding, his arm
strength, his reaction.
All of them are top-notch for one of
the best defensive Cards in the game.
However, his arm accuracy is simply
just not up to par
with those other defensive attributes,
which definitely makes them underrated
in that stat category.
- A little birdie told me that
the arm accuracy is a little bit lower than 99.
- It's a little lower—I mean, 99, that's—
- Yeah.
- You know, that's, like, perfect.
So his arm accuracy's like a [coughing] 75.
[Coughing] Seventy-five, which is great.
- I heard that through the cough.
- Yeah, I know. I feel like my accuracy is OK.
I have had—my first basemans,
they've had to make
some good plays for me.
There's no doubt. It's true.
They've had to scoop
a lotta balls for me.
There's no question about that.
- Stop being a good teammate.
I'll talk for him.
- But, but—
- That's ridiculous that he's a 75!
- But I feel like I could be
higher than that.
- OK. Because you said
that your first basemans have saved you,
I'm gonna be your
first baseman...kind of.
And I've got a big
glove to make some big saves.
This is your time
to show us all the goods.
- Yeah.
- We're gonna hit some balls to you down
at your beautiful hot corner, the third
base, and I want you to hit the target.
You ready to do this?
- I'm ready to do it. Let's go.
- Let's do it. Ramone,
let's go take a look. OK, Nolan.
You've got this, brother.
- Ready.
- [Lefkoe:] Ooh.
- [Arenado:] Oh, man.
- [Lefkoe:] I actually think it's harder to hit the pole
than it is the glove.
- [Russell:] It was.
- [Lefkoe:] Fields it. Whips it. Wow!
- Ooh. OK. Ohhh!
- I hit his head! I hit his head. I got his head.
- Let's up the ante.
- OK, what are you thinkin'?
- You're already plus-15, maybe 20.
- [Lefkoe:] OK.
- [Russell:] If you can hit the small glove,
there may be a 99
arm accuracy on the line here.
- Wow.
- No pressure.
- This is what I've been waiting for.
That's it.
- That would give you 99 arm accuracy,
99 fielding and 99 arm strength.
- [Lefkoe:] Wow.
- [Russell:] But no pressure.
- In the world of sports video games, there
is no number more revered than 99.
- Ninety-nine.
And that is on the line.
- That is on the line.
- [Lefkoe:] How many throws does he get?
- Five.
- If I can't get it in five,
I don't deserve it, all right?
- Let's get it.
- A 99 on the line, feelin' fine.
- Ninety-nine arm accuracy is on the line.
- Round 2. Oh!
- Oooh.
- [Together:] Oh!
- Oh, my gosh.
- Like 12 inches too low.
- No!
- [Russell:] There it is.
- Last one?
- Last one.
- OK.
All right, hold on. Hold on.
- If I don't get it, I don't deserve it.
- Let's take a break.
- That's what it comes down to.
- Take a break.
- Here it is.
- All right, last one. Ready?
- For 99, feelin' fine.
- No way!
- I thought that went between my face and the glove.
- I think it did.
- [Lefkoe:] It's OK. It's OK.
This is why it's—
- [Arenado:] That's all I got.
- [Lefkoe:] This is why I appreciate Nolan.
What I'm feeling, the energy out of you right now
is you're a little bit disappointed.
We went into that final throw plus-15.
So he's a 90 arm accuracy.
What is this gonna do
to his overall rating?
- It's probably gonna bump him to a 90.
- How ya feelin'? We're
looking at the replays right now.
You're, like, an inch away.
- [Arenado:] Yeah. Yeah.
- [Lefkoe:] That last one...
- [Arenado:] I mean, I feel good about it,
but I still, I feel a little disappointed.
A little bad time, yeah.
I mean, I swear that
went right through your head and the glove.
- There's part of me that's OK that you didn't bust up the face.
- [Laughing]
- It's a big day.
- Bunts went up.
Throwing accuracy now a 90.
- Yeah.
- MLB The Show.
- Do you have a message for all the gamers out
there that are thinking about using you?
- Well, if you wanna lay down
a bunt in a big situation, I got you.
And I'm gonna make my plays for you guys. I promise.
- You're the man.
- Yeah, appreciate you boys.
- Appreciate you, man.
I don't like that you smashed my face,
but I did find it entertaining.
So that was good.
- That was awesome.